avec ça tu vas bien ça va merci je t'en
prie suis contente de ce mois de mars
écoulé le mois des retours à la
végétation les samples et puis petit à
petit l'été approche
bon après à vous de voir quel type de
conversation vous entretenir avec avec
sa quête il dort au lasso ou la mort
avec en tout cas c'est plutôt cool vous
avez donc
[Musique]
et je vous parle lui d'un produit en fin
d'année de deux produits deux ans non
dans une boîte vous allez voir un truc
que je trouve vraiment très intéressant
qui va vous aider à mieux vous connecter
chez vous internet et ça c'est très
important notamment pour regarder des
vidéos sur youtube pour aller faire des
jeux pour regarder la 4 car ça c'est
vraiment cool et le deuxième fois kim
écrit bonjour tout le temps d'aimer ça
c'est comme ça donc je vous disais deux
produits en un dans une seule et même
boîte qui va vous aider pour vous
connecter à internet et écouter de la
musique en haute qualité
c'est ça or be or by voice je sais pas
si vous connaissez orbi warby voice
c'est n'est de dire qu'ils fabriquent
salle ornée de dire vous connaissez
j'imagine quand même médias fabriquent
des produits qui sont vraiment vraiment
cool beaucoup connu pour les questions
de connexion justement audi routeur mal
de choses et là il nous sortir un
produit il ya quelques mois
or big buck's alors ordi voice est quoi
or by voice ces réalités deux produits
en le premier produit c'est un routeur
très sympa design juste hop je vous
reçois quelques instants et couplé à une
enceinte connectés qui est là juste là
ça c'est l'enceinte
or by voice alors l'idée c'est quoi
l'idée c'est que vous avez votre routeur
qui connecté à votre box qui lui va
diffuser internet
arrêtez de m'écrire maintenant messieurs
dames qui est connecté dans toute votre
maison qui rayonne oui maman tout va
bien hockey khl il rayonne dans toute
votre maison vous permet de vous
connecter en wifi façon complètement
optimisé grâce à une technologie tri
bande ça c'est orbi et qui va se
connecter à orbi voice or by voice c'est
le satellite hylas permettent de
prolonger votre connexion wifi en gros
il faut imaginer vous avez une maison ou
un grand appartement très grand
appartement mais imaginons vous avez une
maison fait chausser première étage
deuxième étage tant mieux pour vous et
un garage à l'extérieur votre or be qui
est connectée va rayonner bien au rez de
chaussée premier étage à l'extrémité un
petit peu moins et dans le garage c'est
un peu la galère
vous prenez votre satellite orbi voice
vous allez poser à laitages vous le des
centres et un petit peu orbi et orbi
voice grâce à technologie tri bande vont
se connecter ensemble ce qui fait que
vous allez avoir un réseau wifi
complètement optimisé avec la même
connexion que c'est hyper transparente
vous déplacer dans votre maison vous
avez pas besoin d'aller vous connecter
au satellite s'est complètement
invisible ces pratiques
rapid c'est franchement bien et ça vous
permet d'avoir internet par tout ça
c'est le principe de orbi et son
satellite mais avec orbi voice qui est
derrière s'est carrément mieux niveau
reparle qu'est ce qui vous permet de
faire envie voice en virus en fait c'est
une enceinte connectés intelligente
arman cardon très grosse qualité audio
est compatible amazon avec ça avec ça ça
farte nous et j'ai l'impression que la
séance ne va pas aujourd'hui
voilà donc vous voyez c'est plutôt cool
je vais vous expliquer rapidement
comment ça se connectent comment ça
marche une application qui est dédié qui
est vraiment hyper pratique c'est très
intuitif s'écouler franchement je trouve
ça pour à solutionner la vie à pas mal
de groupes
on va commencer par se regardent et orbi
commence à vraiment vous allez voir
c'est très sympa avant toute chose il
faut me promettre que vous regardez pas
le bordel
vous êtes sûr ok ça c'est mon placard à
connexion et là vous avez orbi alors je
vous avais dit regardez pas le bordel
faut que je range c'est un peu le bazar
alors l'idée c'est que orbi va être
connecté à votre box moi ici j'ai une
bbox je suis chez bouygues telecom la
collection les hyper cool ce qui fait
que vous gardez votre box connecte à
internet ce que je vais faire par contre
c'est que je vais connecter mon orbi
directement à ma bosse donc là où vous
voyez j'ai mon câble internet qui va la
kippa requis par qui part si vous suivez
un peu le chemin de câbles et
franchement c'est le hasard ça va vous
emmener jusqu ici vous avez orbite est
connectée c'est hyper simple il vous
suffit de le brancher de le relier et
lui il va diffuser dans tout votre
appartement je vous invite parade et le
bordel donc là j'ai envie qu'elle a qui
diffuse et qui va également se connecter
hormis maintenant on va aller jeter un
coup d'oeil aux satellites hormis voice
notre cher or by voice qui est juste là
lui par contre à capter directement le
wifi qui arrive d'orbit lui seul
satellite pour vous connecter suffit de
brancher sur le port à secteur bien sur
l'allumé deux ports ethernet
rationnellement je les utilise pas et le
bouton synchronisée pour qu'ils se
reconnaissent
ça c'est franchement hyper simple bien
évidemment il vous faudra vous créez un
compte
netgear mais vous allez voir pour
synchroniser orbi et urbi voice c'est
très facile ils communiquent très
facilement ensemble il ya un petit
process à suivre mais vous inquiétez pas
c'est très simple une fois que tous les
deux ont communiqué ensemble vous avez
dans l'appli vous paramétrez votre
compte et ce qui est très intéressant
que ça puisqu'elle vous permet de gérer
quand même pas mal de choses de mon côté
j'ai déjà fait la synchronisation dont
bon ça va être très très simple or be
vous
v la paf de votre appli elle est là ça
permet de gérer vos satellites ça j'ai
voulu montrer mais pour vous connecter
il faut passer par l'apli et c'est
franchement c'est simple vous voyez
typiquement ici on voit qu'on est en
ligne un satellite c'est leur big boys
qui est là et vous avez les
périphériques qui sont connectés
périphériques connectés moi j'ai mon
macbook pro j'ai mon galaxy s 10 ce qui
l a connecté et je peux ensuite je veux
dire les activer désactiver les
permissions à internet donc si je vous
tournez en qu'ils puissent plus venir
paf désactive par exemple si j'ai prêté
une tablette à mon fils je peux la
désactiver si je plus qui l'accès
internet mais pour qu'ils aillent
travailler faire ses devoirs un s'amuse
ou faire ce qu'il veut c'est
complètement possible
donc ça c'est cool vous avez bien
évidemment le mappage de votre réseau
vous voyez moi j'ai ma connexion
internet
j'ai mon routeur et qui communique avec
orbi en satellite qui est juste là mais
j'ai bien évidemment du contrôle
parental et ça c'est franchement hyper
cool alors moi je n'ai pas activé et
vous pouvez activer ça c'est vraiment
intéressant pour vos enfants
bien évidemment vous pouvez complètement
calculer votre débit internet faire un
test de vitesse vous avez bien
évidemment le contrôle vocal avec amazon
alexa les paramètres de votre iphone
votre ecid et votre mot de passe
wifi invité la mesure du trafic enfin
c'est assez cool et vous avez ensuite
plein de paramètres pour venir regarder
vos paramètres plus de nelly rajouter un
satellite nouvelle configuration enfin
voyez la gestion des comptes c'est très
complet et ça c'est assez sympa
concernant or by voice moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est le design je trouve qu'il
est très très très bien réussi audio
signé harman cardon quand vous
connaissez la qualité du maroc c'est
franchement cool vous avez un tweeter de
1 pouces vous avez un haut parleur de
3,5 pouces le design est super beau
j'aime beaucoup ce côté un petit peu là
voyez space 2 turbines donne un côté
dynamique vous avez bien la signature
ici arman cardon est sûr de suivre
trouvé bien quatre microphones pour bien
vous écoutez ici vous pouvez venir
couper le son ou venir l'activé couper
le micro
si vous voulez pas qu'on vous écoute
vous pouvez le faire couper le son et le
micro voyez là pour le coup ça se mue en
rouge vous réactivez et là vous réglez
votre son voyez on le voit qu'à petites
lumières le volume sonore avec ça tu vas
bien ça va merci je t'en prie suis
contente de ce mois de mars écoulé le
mois du retour à la végétation naissante
et puis petit à petit et l'été approche
bon après à vous de voir quel type de
conversation vouloir contenir avec avec
ça quel type de relation vous l'avoir
avec en tout cas c'est plutôt cool vous
avez donc amazon musée
et que vous avez spotify mais en compte
premium bien évidemment uniquement 10
heures de la même manière et pas une
application vous pouvez venir utiliser
avec amazon avec ça comme on utiliserait
une enceinte
amazon alexa un peu classique donc ça
c'est aussi très intéressant on a donc
une meilleure connexion wifi wifi
tribande signé né d'hier avec orbi ça
c'est cool
vous avez une enceinte connectés audio
signé harman kardon
vous avez une enceinte intelligente avec
amazon alexa vous avez une très belle
couverture wifi chez vous dans
l'ensemble de votre maison appartement à
voir si vous avez duplex triplex enfin
ça c'est à vous de voir un produit qui
est pratique simple à configurer
vraiment cool fiable et qui vous coûte
un peu moins de 500 euros
je sais c'est une somme mais à côté de
ça en terme de qualité vous avez un truc
qui est vraiment bien et vous pouvez
rajouter d'autres satellites si besoin
si vous avez un chaton vous pouvez
complètement le connecter en wifi avec
le même ssid et ça pour le coup c'est
vraiment intéressante parce que c'est
complètement transparent et bien
évidemment si ce projet vous intéresse
vous avez un lien en bas dans la
description à la gambie fini les
coupures de wifi leaf fini les zones
mortes vous avez un truc est bien qui va
vite qui est pratique
moi je trouve ça plutôt cool et demain
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire qu'est-ce que vous avez des
besoins en termes de wifi est-ce que
vous galérez est-ce que vous avez des
zones mortes et est ce que vous pensez
qu'une solution comme orbi avec envie
voice pourrait vous aider vous
solutionner la vie vous marquez tout ça
en bas moi je trouve ça plutôt
intéressant je trouve ça plutôt cool est
ce que j'aime vraiment là-dessus c'est
le côté qualité audio avec l'enceinte
connectés harman kardon
c'est juste un régal des voix tout ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire vous
avez délibérément profiter mes
différentes pistes qui s'affiche par là
haut par là vous allez pouvoir voir
pleins d'objets différents découvrir des
smartphones des objets connectés plainte
school voilà je 12 embrasse je vous
envoie du gros becs des gros bisous où
que vous soyez dites moi où est ce que
vous êtes toujours très intéressé par
savoir vous qui me regarder dans quel
coin est ce que vous vous situez en
france en europe en afrique afrique du
nord afrique du sud en inde en chine
canada etats unis brésil joue un peu les
stats sur youtube analytics mais
j'aimerais mieux ça va vous où vous êtes
quels endroits quelle ville mark et moi
tout ça en bas on commentaire soyez
sages
bon et prenez soin de vous à bientôt tu
as tort